what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel today we are
going to be reacting to some fresh and
fit content but we have two special
guests welcome to the channel guys hi
what's up
um feel free first give you guys's
channel name to introduce yourselves to
the people
ladies fast so yeah lady head destiny
[Music]
hey you have one special guest and then
we have Kelly okay my name is Destiny
Okay instagram.com Destiny youtube.com
Destiny I am the one special guest and
then go ahead Kelly introduce yourself
he's okay
um let's have the real special guest
start to talk real special yeah I agree
with that real special real special uh
I'm Kelly Jean and I am a cosplayer from
England so hi nice to meet y'all
today we are going to be reacting to
Destiny's time on fresh and fit
um do you want to pull the clip Up was
this the last time you were on or when
when was this
um yeah I'm gonna say last time looks
like it okay I actually have not seen
this clip so I'm excited what was more
chaotic like what was more nothing has
been more chaotic than the show I was on
two nights ago I like anything in my
life it's been working out for that so
yeah that's fair that's fair point
I clicked it blessing
Destiny Okay I feel like women love more
I think on average I think women are
more emotionally mature and I think that
love outside of like the fairy tale
requires a lot of actual like emotional
upkeep a lot of emotional labor I think
a lot of guys can't put that in I don't
think feeling possessive or jealous is
love just because you get like really
asked mad if your woman does something
or if you get like really jealous or
possessive what is the question he asked
I think women in general I think they're
letting me pause it but yeah the
question was who loves more men or women
how do you quantify love that's such a
bizarre question yeah I don't know it's
kind of a silly question but they're I
think their method of quantifying it is
that like any man will love any woman so
therefore men love more
um whereas I think if you make love more
conditional that feels like more of a
love thing to me but I mean it's kind of
it's a very subjective question but
it's very broad who loves more I feel
like when a girl actually like
I feel like a girl loves more like when
you're that guy but in general like men
Love More
I don't know what that means okay like
okay so if
I already know he's gonna he's so ready
I'm not I'm just like I'm just chilling
I'm just waiting for you no go ahead
tell me no no I know how he is I know
how he is okay no I feel like when a
girl like okay Jack and Rose on the
Titanic right yeah okay Rose had this
whole fiance right she jumps off the
ship for this guy she just met so when
she felt like she was in love with the
guy she's going crazy she's doing crazy
[__] okay but I feel like in general
like most men are the fiance they're
Jack but their girl isn't like or
they're not Jack the other guy's name
you know what I'm talking about yeah
oh my god did she did Rose have a
college degree do you think probably
probably she was 26. oh no on Instagram
too much probably
um yeah it's it's a it's a silly it's
hard to quantify like everybody can get
obsessed with each other like everybody
can be weird every it's I think it's
hard to know him yeah but I will it's
not like you could find facts
it out I will say on these shows though
that when you're saying that like
I don't care what you say but if you're
a guy doing a one like advocating for a
one-ended open relationships it's hard
to say that you love there more than
your like girlfriend or wife does I
think you don't think it's different for
men and for women cheating no because
you're I'm not you're
you're in like the open on both ends
okay I don't go ahead
no go for it okay
I'm polite I don't no you're not gonna
be worn go for it no I just mean like
isn't that awkward like isn't it I don't
know because I'm just thinking like like
if you look at it from a historical
perspective like women had to get the
highest value Guy where men they wanted
to like reproduce so from a historical
perspective like what value would that
bring
like a woman being promiscuous well so
my Approach is is that I want to be
promiscuous you know I want to be
promiscuous I can't tell my girlfriend
not to be promiscuous so it has to be
like I don't think relationships work if
you have like maximum openness on one
and a maximum closing together that's
always going to be a recipe for disaster
so then in my world it's either do you
want to be monogamous or do you just not
want to be like married or date anybody
and just be like single be a [__] boy
forever
yeah I mean I wouldn't really prefer to
be
to be in chip where someone's open on
one end either but
I feel like
a lot of times like girls do it for free
you know what I mean girls do what for
free where it's like open on one end and
close no that is unbelievably rare and
if the girl finds out she's gonna she
will get mad and leave the guy
for free she's saying that women
naturally gravitate towards or allow
guys to like cheat and don't care that
much oh I don't think so I don't think
so I actually think that like women like
to be cheated on huh
no not particularly but it's like every
time I ask the girls on the show it'll
be like
we'll talk about cheating right and um
they'll bring up their ex that cheated
and my next question is always something
wrong blessing oh
oh did I oh sorry okay
um but my next question is always like
did you stay and the question they
always say yes yeah but guys and girls
and then and then I asked them like do
when did you guys break up like when did
it end it's always when they stop
cheating and I'm like why why didn't you
leave the first time if you didn't like
the cheating like that doesn't make
sense to me okay so what happens is is
people get into obsessed with each other
they break up it's called yo-yoing where
people will date and they break up and
they come back
but I'm saying they didn't break up when
they when he cheated the first time so
it's like in my head if you didn't like
the cheating you would leave when he
cheated yeah some people I mean there's
a lot of things and when I first heard
this I thought it was crazy I was like
there's no way girls like similar to an
addiction it's the roller coaster and
then they go back because they miss yeah
but they didn't leave that's what I'm
saying okay they go back and that they
have a fight and then they're still
together that's the same thing but then
then why would you leave when he stops
cheating probably because the rest of
the relationship was still messed up in
some way that's what I'm imagine do you
really believe that most women like
being cheated on yeah I think I do I
didn't before I started the show okay I
did it before I started the show and
then I I just had the same because it's
like I just start to meet the same
people over and over again I'm just like
this is a pattern okay did any of them
tell you they liked being cheated on I
mean they didn't say that but their
actions it's like it's like their
actions showed it do you think women
like being abused do I think they like
being a b why do we gotta go to abuse
well I'm just asking there's a lot of
women that's what they do they'll be
like we'll be talking about a and then
he brings up B because a lot of women I
didn't say abused I didn't say abused a
lot of women like to stay in abusive
relationships so do they like it because
they stay there
um
so I feel like this is like a trap
question it's like a trap it's like this
is
like to be addicts well because you're
like the choices you know honestly I
think some addicts do I do I know this
is I have relatives that are addicts oh
and it's like
yeah okay they freaking they just keep
doing the same thing over and over again
based okay
is love just because you get like really
asked mad if your woman does something
or if you get like really jealous or
possessive one doesn't you love her more
so I think women in general are willing
to put more emotional work in the
relationships
would you also say this out to the
argument here that women men more than
men because with women what do you think
uh that has to be true you have to say
true
yeah I mean I think that's true but it's
such a dumb question why is it a dumb
question because there might be a
different Tolerance on both sides for
bad or stupid Behavior right
yeah but like why don't you just answer
the question that's what you do you like
I think I do it
like I don't know and I'm like did I say
I don't know through this video at this
right or only two minutes that's why I
like having Destiny on I disagree with
Destiny I think men love far more wait
go back I didn't hear my answer
sorry I'm
trigger happy I love this lady that's my
future not right
okay your future second wife do you want
a second one yeah third and a fourth
third and a fourth I'm gonna convert to
Islam so I get all these guys to come
and defend me when I do bad stuff okay
because you get like really asked mad if
your woman does something or if you get
like really jealous or possessive one
doesn't you love her more so I think
women in general will need to put more
emotional work in the relationships so
I'll say Layla boy would you also say
this out to the argument here that women
men more than men because women what do
you think
um break up with I don't know see you
said I don't know you said I don't know
I don't know oh he's doing it again
listen I know the divorce the divorce
answer is women
I don't know just anecdotally why would
I just why would I fight anecdot versus
oh my gosh it's just like it's like
sometimes it's like water is wet
okay
um I don't I don't I know for divorce I
think women initiate divorcement I don't
know for breakups wouldn't you think
that it's probably similar it might be
it might or there might be reasons why
it's the opposite I don't know men love
women under far less conditions than
women love men that sounds like the
opposite of love to me well if you love
under far less conditions that sounds
like desperation I don't want somebody
that loves me for like one or two
reasons or whatever right I want them to
be a lot of reasons why they love me but
what I'm saying see that's that's what I
was saying earlier that's what I was
saying earlier I feel like man
it's like
I'm I'm gonna butcher this I know I know
but it's like I feel like when men love
women it's like
it's more common for them to be the
fiance in the situation where it's like
women have more conditions for them to
be like really in love so when they're
really in love they're like super in
love but the average girl like isn't
yeah but then it comes down to semantic
of like what does it mean to be more in
love right yeah like if somebody tells
me like I love you and I was like well
why
um because I think you're funny and I'm
like okay what else I don't know I just
think you're really funny and that's it
it's like okay but I'm just like oh I
love you because you're you know tall
good at volleyball red hair and they've
got like runs a good Studio they have
like 20 reasons like oh wow this person
really loves me you know that's what
would be my feeling but then it's like
well what does it mean to love more
there well in that case men love more
about my students I've never had a guy
care about myself
know you well enough okay I'm just
drawing into whatever I see like I love
at first sight like it's more of a
simple
yeah like the more immediate the more
the more quicker type of thing but then
it's a question of like who loves more
than if you fall into love with every
person you meet because you think they
look good is that loving more than
somebody that's like well I love a very
specific person but I love them a lot
you know I almost I feel like people
fall in love based on how the other
makes them feel at least from a woman's
point of view do you think that's true
for men isn't it just hormones and
chemistry yeah I mean that's probably
true for everybody right like how you
feel about somebody is how they make you
feel about them yeah
is that for a man to love a woman she
does not have to jump us through as many
hoops and meet as many requirements as
for a woman needs to love a man so in
other words the guy's got to reach a
certain level to even be acknowledged by
the woman however that woman she could
be mediocre and still get the Garner the
love from a man who is superior to in
every way which you know from a
biological standpoint that makes sense
because men dig down and women take so
we make this is like criticizing women
for having standards here I'm not sure
that's always what it is yeah I don't
think it's criticizing I think it's
describing he's literally I think it's
this I think it's true you don't think
that's true he's literally writing a
book called women deserve less I think
that's funny you know that's you're
laughing that's funny it's like you
can't
Jesus
it's funny but I mean I'm saying it's
like yesterday wait there's semantics do
you remember that you asked a question
yesterday at the end of that Tate
interview where you were like do you
think that um jokes are just jokes or
something and it's like yeah they're
jokes but they always like hinted
something true so yeah I think people in
the red pill communities the general I I
thought is that women's standards are
too high who would read a book like that
presumably not women and then men just
get the idea that we need less how is
that gonna help them I'm gonna I'm gonna
buy the book I'm sure I'm gonna buy it
yeah okay well you can let us know I
guess I'll give you guys my summary
that's great you'll have it on your
bookshelf right next to your own
self-published like Pearl's guide to
whale hunting or whatever right
I never even thought about writing a
book but you know what maybe I will
gotcha it won't be whale it'll be well
spotting it'll be like
well-defending oh okay gotcha genderless
who loves more somebody with high
standards or low standards all low
sequel because that's what you're
essentially saying obviously the person
with high standards loves more because
you'll be more selective of your partner
so of course you're gonna love that
partner more but that's kind of what I
was saying with the jacket okay it's
only 100 contingent upon the other
parties ability to provide and uh and
perform is my point like a woman doesn't
have a burden of performance
I mean if you're telling guys to like
look for a woman that's just young and
can cook then of course there's no
burden of performance yeah but again
like how much of Love is that like I
love you so much like why because I can
cook and I'm young I can find a million
girls that can cook in here if you've
got two reasons for it then like yeah
that is true but what I'm saying is that
if you take a majority of men versus a
majority of women a majority of men
would like a majority of women however a
majority of women definitely don't like
a majority of men yeah I agree that's
why I think women love more because when
they pick somebody The Selective about
it they put more time and energy into it
for sure whereas for a guide woman is a
lot more replaceable so I think what
Myron is trying to say though is that
like if guys stop doing the things like
if a guy's jobless for like two years
the girl's gone basically so like how do
how do women love more more if if the
guy stops doing that stuff I feel like
this is more or less this is like
differently it's more intelligently more
planned or sort of and then more simply
on that and and the side of the men but
I mean I mean simply can be Charming to
like fall in love with someone with that
connection without really putting a lot
of thought into it it's not necessarily
inherently evil or something but the
fact that women feel like they have to
take more things off so like they feel
safe I suppose it's also valid yeah I
feel like it's it's hard because it's so
subjective I might be an outlier here
but I really don't like the concept of
unconditional love like I have worked
pretty hard in my life to accomplish a
certain amount of things I've worked
pretty hard to present myself in a
certain way I would hope that the person
that loves me loves me for those things
and if I just became some type of slob
that lived at home and did nothing all
day and was jobless for two years and
didn't do anything that they would
probably not love me anymore because if
they did then what like what if you're
what if your wife got fat would you feel
like that the equivalent
um I like 300 pounds okay 300 pounds
We're Gonna Roll that ass down the
stairs
kind of conditional both ways well I
feel like that's the equivalent as a
woman gaining a ton of weight well no no
she's gone she said she's gone he agrees
with me leave the whales
300 pounds
Lee Wales he agrees at 300 pounds yeah
of course because you're talking about
it but that's like where's the cutoff if
what like 200 250 like when are you
leaving I don't know I don't mind
somebody that's chubby if she got like
chubby that'd be fine I'm not with her
just because of the way that she looks
there's a whole other side she's got
like a 30 pounds like she's she's
there's a lot of things about her that I
like like she's into working out she's
into doing outdoorsy stuff she likes to
go adventuring traveling my guess is
that if she became 300 pounds she's
probably not doing any of that anymore
right so there's other things that are
yeah there's other things that are
changing for her to become a 300 pound
person yeah but
come on 300 you know you know even if
she was still doing that stuff at 300
pounds you'd be gone I already told you
300 is way over the line leave the
whales man leave he agrees with me no I
don't think no because I don't know I am
so glad we're on the same time
300 is a lot wouldn't you agree I like
how earlier she was like
this analogy and then now she's like
well what if she weighs 300 pounds
oh no I just said I just said what about
200 250 I said how much leeway does it's
not my fault you wouldn't answer the
question I did I said that I don't mind
yeah I said okay so 30 pounds I don't
know what she would look like with 30
pounds more it's fine 30 pounds more
would be okay he has just convinced me
instead of leave the whales leave the
orcas too oh my God leave the hippos I
think chicken game at first I was just I
was just gonna say whales and Wales is
like 250 270 plus roughly but now I'm
gonna add to it just because of you
gotcha thank you would you leave your
guy if he gained 200 pounds
um
oh my God the biggest cap no I I dated a
guy that was a significantly bigger than
me yeah would you know I didn't ask in
your pastor saying right now would you
date a guy and then he gained weight and
he weighed 300 350 pounds
um three that's a lot no I wouldn't say
you can leave the men whale too okay so
male and female whales are getting dead
um I think it would depend on at what
point in the relationship you are
because if I'm like 70 and my partner
gets really large for some medical
reason I probably wouldn't leave them
because I've built a whole life with
them sure but not really as much of a
problem but obviously at this point in
my life I would because you want that
attraction I feel like you're gonna lose
it I do feel like once you have kids
it's not about you anymore so I will say
the kids if I had children I'd probably
you know I'd be like go to the gym let's
go running you know you know let's go
300 pounds I'll just I'll just start to
feed him less you know what I mean I was
like yeah it would depend on how they
got to that weight right yeah like what
things caused that to happen and other
personality changes
can I have a second plate I'll be like
oh we're out of food that's you go to
the McDonald's for you and your two kids
you get three Happy Meals right I don't
you
I was like oh you know you might step
out of another or whatever it's like
okay well how much do you actually love
your woman you're willing to do
something like that like that has
something to do with what about you like
how much do you actually couldn't I say
that to you don't you actually love your
woman if you're willing to step out on
her well but we have the same rules
yeah but it's not the same it's the same
question see it's like he doesn't answer
the question no I think it's if you have
the same set of rules on both sides then
it shows that you engage with the topic
in a different way I don't associate the
people that I have sex with I don't
associate that with like hardcore love
that's just for me that just doesn't
work that way right that's I was gonna
make your mom joke
um no but the um yeah I was he's always
bullying I am but but if you but if you
believe that like love and sex go
together
and that's why your girl's not allowed
to sleep around but you are that type of
discrepancy is doesn't work for me I
don't think women are like tie more
emotion to sex than men do I think on
like average probably okay so that's you
wouldn't see why it's different then if
you would agree that like by and large
women tie emotion more to sex on average
but the difference I don't think let me
oh let me answer your question before
you railroad me down that well they
engage with sex differently when in an
open relationship they're actually okay
mock you okay if you want to lay out
your whole Kingdom before I thought
you're being polite here
um that's the same question I don't even
remember so the question you're asking
is if women and men engage with sex
differently doesn't that mean it's okay
for men to [__] everybody and for women
to [__] nobody not say [__] everybody I
said different wouldn't you see that it
is different there are probably some
women that can engage with sex without
it being a super emotional experience
there are probably some men that can
engage with sex that'll be a super
emotional experience there's probably a
few more men than women but I think both
of them tie emotions and sex together
pretty well maybe when we have when we
have these conversations though we're
talking about the average we're not
talking about the exceptions
you were specifically asking about my
relationship so I'm telling you for my
relationship that was not a general
question oh you're right you were right
that's true God I love it when you say
that oh thank you oh my goodness I need
to SoundCloud August flip that one
that's gonna be right next don't
understand okay oh no don't do it don't
clip me you love the person it
absolutely does why because it requires
you to step out of your own selfish
realm of reference to see how your
partner feels about something the only
prioritize the things that you want in
life that says something about how you
view love of another person
it's not really prioritizing it's just
doing what you want to do yeah that's
called being selfish it's usually what
you do when you don't love somebody
so they can get what they want but we
can get what's going on as well first
time he's going to considered that as a
possibility he's like staring into the
abyss he's like wait is he right what
you want if you're dating a cat women
love selfish men though that's my
problem
Oh you just you just like say the
randomness most like what is like the
dumbest wrongest opinion yeah would you
be the selfish guy yeah why do you keep
saying I've been with you're not anymore
okay right would you selfish in which
way yeah would you date a selfish guy I
like guys okay when I say selfish I mean
like guys that are following their
purpose and put themselves first look at
it oh okay and so it's like okay he's so
ready I am God but I'm waiting for you
see I'm like winding up my spring it's
like it's like go ahead you scare me a
little bit I'm like you should do this
go ahead
finisher finish your thoughts I forgot
what I was even saying I forgot
selfishness oh yeah I do come on I feel
like this is Tale As Old As Time We Know
women love [__] that's not true
okay go ahead my question was gonna be
let's say you start dating a guy and
he's like listen I love you and I it's
great what you're doing out here pearly
but um I need you to move to Germany
because that's where I live and I'm not
moving anywhere for your career and
let's say he earns like 60 000 Euro a
year working in Germany and he's telling
you have to move there would that be
like attractive to you like God he's so
driven to just not care at all about my
life I was gonna move to Germany next
year anyways for volleyball yeah it
sounds like that wouldn't even be so bad
Germany the German so I'm gonna like you
totally avoiding that question I think
we know the answer okay you asked if I'd
moved to Germany for him and I said and
then you said well I almost moved to
Germany because I was playing volleyball
which is a totally how about a country
you wouldn't like I'm seeing so it was
how about Zimbabwe
your husband is from Zimbabwe answer
carefully I just think long term that
probably wouldn't work I don't know what
it's about way
and a bowl they want to eat you it's not
like both of you have Fair ass right
but what we ask for is so small though
compared to what other women to be
disloyal to maybe knock another woman up
to maybe step out of your girl and just
start dating another how is that a small
ass not only that bringing something
back home yeah
and you like oh [__] I got another girl
pregnant like you're in the whole
[__] world of Agony there
yeah you know it's interesting I
actually kind of agree with you there
wow thanks oh another sound clip oh my
God I'm gonna have so many Dono sounds
after this oh my gosh I don't know what
a Dono sound is but I feel like I won't
like it and he's just gonna make like
with somebody donates money it like
plays a noise so it'll be pearly saying
like I agree with you oh my gosh don't
do that
um no
um just so you do not consent yeah I
don't I don't consent to that okay no
he's supposed to care about this oh you
should have made better decisions so
that's all right well we're all about
accountability here
now when it comes to like I don't think
cheating is ideal but I do think
cheating is different for men and for
women like I do think if you're gonna
have like an open type relationship on
either end that's going to cause more
problems but you know I I do think it's
different for men and for women
are you smiling like that go ahead
like women aren't going to be okay with
their guys cheating on them I don't know
what else to say like it's it's so
awesome if that was true so every girl I
ask this on the show wouldn't would it
would it stay and then leave later it's
just quite odd true I think the same
about Abused women all the time why
don't you just leave now he's gonna
bring him why don't you just leave why
not just get out he's gonna bring abuse
into this thing here is that and the
reason why I I disagree and I get what I
see where you're going with is saying
that women have far more requirements
therefore they love harder because those
requirements are harder to find what I'm
would you be with a guy if he cheated on
you
I think we already asked this yeah when
I'm serious again did you say no
um
would it depend on the type of cheat
imagine she had redder hair than you she
was taller than you she had a better
Studio
um I mean I think it's dishonest to say
I wouldn't okay I think it's dishonest
to say I wouldn't
um yeah okay
I wouldn't I wouldn't be like Oh yay it
wouldn't make you more competitive
it might it might
saying is that by having more
requirements that makes that makes it
where their love is a hundred percent
contingent upon that man's performance
so it's fleeting because if that guy
loses right what he had
that woman will leave and I've always
said it that you know shots roller I
agree with him on this women love
opportunistically while men tend to love
idealistically I think that one you
already said yeah I think the fact that
they love opportunistically
proves they're in itself what is loving
that they love They Don't Love
I mean it goes back for like loving a
guy for what he has
more so and it's not necessarily A Bad
Thing
um but would that really be love or
would it just be pretending I mean in
the fresh and fit model of the world
well what is love is the question in the
Friendship family of the world women go
after men for their resources and men go
afterwards yeah but they don't say it's
a bad thing like they're not they're not
I'm just saying you could do
just
well I don't even know they think women
can love or if it's just like a reptile
brain like okay I mean I just think that
our I think the argument is that women
can't love in the same way that men can
because like it requires more for us to
love someone
why can't you guys ever talk about I'm
sorry not you guys because you're not a
red pillar I'm so sorry almost to that
but I get frustrated sometimes because
the way that all of these people not you
talk about relationships is so sad like
it's like oh yeah like women are out
here dating for resources and men are
looking for the youngest freshest lowest
body count woman and that's like all
they have to say about relationships
it's only sad if you look at it like
that it's more of a description it's
true it's not true for healthy
relationships and it is sad if you care
about relationships like who defines
what is healthy like they're not saying
what's healthy and what's not healthy
they're just describing what it is and
throughout all of time women have gone
for men with more resources and men have
gone forward and women that are younger
and more pure they would have been dead
yeah but because women couldn't work so
of course they went up to resources
because they're gonna work but I'm just
saying that like if you if you think of
like people that are in happy healthy
relationships are you thinking of like
God like she found a guy and it's just
so cool because he gives her so many
resources and it's so cool that he's
like 48 and she's 22. you might not you
might not like like think of it like
that right you might you might not think
of it like that but it's true it's a
description I disagree do you feel like
it's like an ingrained survival Instinct
that we just have as women because we
don't want to die so we like pick the
guys with the most resources I don't
think it's only resources like muscles
but that kind of looks like this if
someone is busy there's like others if
someone is physically fit that
um suggests oh yeah yeah yeah so that's
another resource yeah I think the most
successful relationships require like a
higher level engagement it requires more
work
um it requires like more types of
um there are more things that go into
building a healthy relationship between
two people than just resources on one
side and youth on the other like that
relationship isn't going to last for
more than like six months well I didn't
say it was just resources but yeah I
mean like I think there's things like
culture values like that sort of thing
too but I just think again it's a
description it might not be as detailed
of a description as you'd like
but it's just it's just a description
I don't know why you're saying it's just
a description like that's kind of my
point I said I disagreed with the
description can you not disagree with
the description yeah but how do you what
do you disagree with you don't think
women go after men with resources I
don't think that it's that simplistic
though and also there's a lot of a lot
of the advice which is why I said well
sure but if you're going to add in a
whole bunch of stuff there right that's
like saying like oh like women only date
men with dicks they like and it's like
well I don't know if that's true it's
like well if they have a dick they like
and also if they're like nice and they
provide like a good life then it's like
okay well if you're gonna expand it way
more well then sure I guess I agree so
if you're gonna say like just resources
and just youth then I I guess I'll agree
if you're also going to add in on the
other stuff I mean it just goes down to
like the Bare Bones but then you can add
in other like clearly yeah for those
like this is more like marketing like
those things draw you in we have like
necessarily fall in love with those Bare
Bones aren't going to sustain a
relationship
you're gonna need more than just
resources but it starts with you you
still need resources to start because
women in general
they well bum women do I wish that they
didn't I know so many women in my life
that could do so much better than they
do yeah like why are you with these
people if they could do better than they
would exactly poor women can't poor
women they poor men middle class women
date middle-class man
I think if they could do better they
probably would I mean this is just based
on me knowing that they're very
attractive and the men that the weather
just trash yeah because they end up
getting obsessed with some dumb guy and
then they do the yo-yo thing where they
go back and forth forever they'll have
something in common that bonds them
really hard and then I'll be like you
can do better and the commonality will
be at one point the relationship was
really good like a year or two ago and
they're like chasing that relationship
high for with some super loser dude for
validation
yeah men do they don't live
idealistically they love based on I need
this guy to perform something for me
then I can love him whereas a man is
like okay uh these are my requirements
you're attractive you can cook just like
we discussed before that's good enough
for me and that guy will fall in love
with her versus for her it's like you
need to perform sure so for your
question you've gotta you give a good
qualifier the analysis you're abandoning
which is you don't believe in
unconditional love nobody loves
unconditionally yeah there's always
nobody left right so what so if you're
talking about like a man with very few
requirements and you're going to say
like well if you're not meeting the
performance like a man to a woman then
she's Gonna Leave You Well the probably
the same thing is true for the man as
well right really so you think the
average man would stay with a woman if
she got like battery acid attacked and
lost both legs or something that's not a
condition I think okay I'm gonna tell
you why I think you're wrong because the
amount of whales
I mean that's an exception though you
know by and large men don't like fat
chicks men stay with their fat wives all
the time
all the time are they all so fat yes
Bolding yep there's a lot of fat people
fat people stay with fat people but
women by and large are fatter than men
women and if you go in the U.S the
woman's always fatter hold on I'm sorry
isn't the average weight of a man like
40 pounds over the average weight of a
woman
yeah also men just statistically hired
no I think the average weight of a woman
is more than a guy I could be wrong I
don't think you're right just because of
the height difference alone right that
would be insane but also there's just
more men that are overweight
yeah hold on I gotta look it up or
whatever so in the U.S the average BMI
for a man is 26.6 and the average BMI
for women is 26.5 oh I stand corrected
and that means the men probably have 40
to 50 pounds more because they're taller
right
but I think it's just fat people stay
with fat people there's always this like
I feel like there's this it's so strange
on these shows they present it as like
poor women are going off and getting
married to millionaire men that doesn't
that's not happening and then like all
these attractive men that are trying
really hard to stay finished are having
to settle for those like whale women I
don't think that happens that's
so common though
it is
I've heard I've seen so many girls get a
ring and get fat like there's so many
girls I went to high school with and
there's guys that get a ring and get fat
the guys just get like skinny fat like I
mean they're not in great shape and the
women are getting skinny fat what do you
mean oh no they're very fast okay well
the data on average says
and it's just the women that are fat on
average they're all about as fat as each
other like that's the status but it's
still good it still goes back to like
the things that women value for men and
men value from women
looks than women it's more we agree with
that right like women it's more just
more so it doesn't mean there's nothing
right but women it's more resources and
Men it's more looks in in general the
trend is changing but in general in
general yeah okay it can be yeah okay I
don't know how much it so I I do agree
that women value resources but I think
it's to a certain point right I don't I
don't think it's like all women want
millionaires yeah you're going to be
realistic stable yeah you can be
realistic about what you can get yeah
not working at McDonald's like it's not
that I don't think that it's as high but
men's superficiality can get quite bad I
don't know when I ask girls it's usually
around like
[Music]
um
in order they'll say in order to fully
submit it's got to be like 90 to 100
here but they're going to work with like
60 to 70 roughly
what's the average here in the UK it's
got to be like 35 or something like that
exactly 35 40. that is exactly what I'm
saying yeah but you're talking to
exceptional people in your show right
whether you're thinking or not they are
these are believe it or not it's not bad
if you want to have kids I feel like a
lot of women that don't want kids before
okay a little bit lower sure but I just
like people are presenting it as like
women that are making like 15 20 care
only looking for guys making like six
figures or more but the reality is poor
people marry poor people be surprised
you would be surprised if you look at
the numbers poor people marry poor
people middle class people married
middle class people when do they marry
them that's the whole point it's like
the girls will go after the guys that
make a lot of money in their 20s and
their 30s get married to the guy that
they because they want a kid no I don't
agree with that I think that's a I think
that's an artifact of women putting off
marriage more because they're going to
school they're working and they have
birth control now now that's been spun
into like they want to ride the cat the
[__] Carousel of like Chad dicks until
they settle for a man but I think the
reality is women are just in general
putting up I mean you've never heard
like women go for bad boys when they're
younger like even my grandma would would
tell you that
but confidence and and the problem is a
lot of [__] are confident and it
requires learning this process to be
like I like confidence but I don't like
[__] but I have to date someone to
figure out that's what they're talking
about though so yeah but don't guys also
so she's she's validating what I'm
saying yeah I agree you go for dumb
women when you're young but but yeah not
dumb women no no guys make bad choices
for women women tend to they have to
learn that the confidence is what they
like not the assholeness yeah I agree
but it's not just women that do that
it's men that do that too
women go after dumb men when they're
young but men but it's like every time
we have a conversation about women you
always have to put butt men because
because show you blame like 95 of the
world's
running yeah women do do this but men do
it too it's not exceptional because my
whole point is that like sorry men and
women I think are way more in common we
have way more commonalities so we do
differences so like yeah but wouldn't
you agree there's some biological
differences
no I think we're exactly the same
yeah obviously
no of course there are some biological
there we make different types of
mistakes I already told you earlier that
like men are more likely to gravitate
towards attractive women and women
versus like men that have like money or
whatever you don't think there's any
commonality with women getting fat after
they get a ring that's not a common I
think everybody can let themselves go
after they get around would you you
think it's equal though yeah that's what
the data seems to say okay otherwise the
BMI of women would be way higher on
average than the BMI of men no okay okay
what would happen to a woman that you
wouldn't be with her anymore I guess if
your standards are really low then maybe
you wouldn't care but again this isn't a
man versus woman this is a high
standards versus low standard the only
standards I need you to cook and I guess
not cheat on me then sure I mean you can
find a lot of people that'll fit the
bill and then again like if if I and my
partner are what are your standards
uh I like people that are reasonably
intelligent I like somebody has a high
level of confidence
um I prefer somebody that works like in
my industry so that it's easy for us to
communicate
um I prefer somebody to be in an open
relationship because I want to [__]
around
um I like somebody that's pretty
flexible so they're able to travel and
adapt a lot because I do like a lot of
crazy stuff I need somebody with a high
degree of emotional tenacity because I
have a lot of insane events that are
going on in my life I need somebody that
is really independent because I can
spend time traveling or get really into
my work
um yeah my I have a lot of there's a lot
of weird stuff you have to deal with
when you date me what about for you
Pearl yeah what are my standards yeah
that no man has managed to meet you
let's hear it see if we can find you
someone yeah your future husband could
be listening to this show right now
so tell him what you're looking for
um I mean I like guys that are family
oriented
um I don't see I feel I feel like he's
so ready to just
there's no wrong answers here okay no um
I like guys that are family oriented
conservative
um not
I like you know I have a height thing he
doesn't have to be taller than me he
could be a little shorter but it can't
be like crazy okay
um
all right
yeah
um
family so just five eleven five ten
conservative five nine five times five
nine five ten okay conservative family
oriented yeah you haven't found that guy
yet
[Laughter]
like there's a lot of people
I don't want to get into too much
wow okay all right okay okay now I'm
curious we got some weird requirements
here
secretly into BDSM oh yeah Jesus
my side and we're asked to describe why
do we love each other and I say okay I
really love my partner because she cooks
really well and she's never [__]
another guy where we're dating and it's
like okay and then she says oh well I
love him because of this and that and
that and that and that yeah who loves
each other more that just seems like a
weird it just seems like a weird thing
to me it's like oh well I like her
because of these two things literally
every other woman I was gonna ask you
all things being equal would you prefer
it if it was like one-sided open or do
you not care
if she was cool with that if she was
just like you know what that's totally
fine
I don't I I really don't I would be
indifferent to it the reason why like if
we're saying like in a perfect
hypothetical world where there would
never be a problem I still don't think I
would character something I personally
care about but I think that
realistically anytime somebody's allowed
to do something in a relationship and
the other person isn't that's always
going to build a lot of resentment I
think you don't ever get jealous I'm
just not that kind of person really no
the planet remember the question I said
who who is closer to unconditional love
oh I didn't hear that yeah yeah
because I said because I said first okay
unconditional love isn't realistic okay
well in that case and the unconditional
love is going to be the one with the
lower standard so if you're a low
standard guy then sure yeah okay and I
mean I I see that you switched the the
point a little bit saying no like you
know men women love more because they
have more standards but my thing is
who's closer to unconditional love and I
would argue it's the men because we have
far less conditions than women do sure
well in that case the the closest
unconditional love will be people with
like down or something right you see
somebody you smile that's what he does
he'll bring up like this random thing
that's such a good counter-existence
it's true I'll just be like this is
we'll be like we'll be talking about A
and B Down syndrome why not just to my
kids we're talking about A and B and
Destiny's like well what about C and
you're like we're talking about A and B
what a great example uh that kid's gotta
love so much that's an unconditional
love right there just feed him oh pet
him I don't know what you do with kids
with Down Syndrome
[Music]
Hey kid why do you have to say Down
syndrome well because I I imagine they
have less never mind I mean
go ahead I mean kids
they do say women are children a lot
well red pillars do why that's weird
because that's what they're looking for
the perfect wife is a child you cannot
you cannot tell me that the girls on the
panel on the last panel we are on we're
not acting like children you cannot tell
me Charlie we're but I think a lot of
the I'm gonna do the thing I think a lot
of guys do too nah you can no I have
done I am the only one in this space
that have done panels equally men and
women I've done full men panels I've
done full women panels the women are
absolutely worse wow they're absolutely
worse you know if that's the if that's
the idea
but let's be honest here a lot of guys
are are real when it comes to shoes
you know I would argue that women are
far more selective than men and more
intelligent when it comes to the mate
selection process versus men are quite
frankly a lot of the time stupid they'll
be with a girl that is using them
abusing them treating them like maybe
yelling at them do you agree with that
um I do partly I do think women are a
little bit more intelligent with their
selection after when they've grown a bit
older I think maybe as teenagers we're
equally stupid maybe they just learn a
little bit faster I feel like I'd have a
hard time generalizing because I see
like I said you you know some I know
some women that are insanely amazing
people they look good they make a lot of
money and they're just with the most
loser-ish guys I don't know why I can
never explain it but I also know guys
that will do like really dumb things
over and over again too that should know
better so people are real dumb sometimes
when it comes to relationships yeah I
don't know if I could generalize it more
to one side or the other I don't know
you can't generalize
I just don't know I know a lot of men
that make a lot of bad decisions I know
a lot of women make a lot of bad
decisions in terms of like who stays in
relationships more
um when dumb steps happening like how
many Abused Women will stay in abusive
relationships for a long time because
they end up getting mind [__] over it
like I think that's stupid
but you know the other thing I've
learned about abused and what they don't
talk about a lot of times they're both
abusing each other
that can't happen sometimes I mean like
every because a lot of girls will come
on my show and they'll be and I know
you'll be like anecdotal like but okay
I'm just like reactive abusing so they
get abused they react back and then it's
like a circle well but that's always the
assumption but how do you know they
didn't hit first
I mean even if they even if they did hit
first I think it's a bit different when
a guy's hitting a woman unfortunately
equal rights equal lefts baby
I seriously I just I feel like if you
shouldn't hit a guy if you don't expect
to get hit back okay hold on weren't you
earlier just saying there are by are you
are there no biological differences
between men and women yeah there are
okay so women hitting men is bad I'm not
going to argue against that it's a
horrible thing and in relationships it
shouldn't happen but I think men hitting
women is a little different because the
capacity to do damage there it's a lot
higher well yeah so I feel like women
then should never hit a guy I agree with
you so it's like why would you hit a guy
if you don't expect to get hit back and
so in an abusive I think under the lot
should be equal
I don't even know what the question I
think originally was who stays in
abusive relationship and now we're
trying to say that like well a guy
should be able to beat the [__] out of a
woman
is that a lot of times what they don't
talk about is that they'll say oh women
are staying with these abusive men but a
lot of times the women are abusing too
and if you talk to people that have
actually worked in those Industries
they'll tell you that I don't think so
because the thing because that's usually
the point that I have to fight on a lot
of people when you talked in these
industries the the repeated phrase is
actually uh Mutual abuse is is
impossible that's not a real thing
they'll say that that's not that that
back and forth doesn't exist I don't
agree with that I think that Mo I think
we saw it a little bit with the Johnny
Depp Amber Heard stuff that there's like
if any relationship that has some abuser
probably both sides are doing symptoms
if that happens to a man with money
power and Status what happens to the
average guy and that's the whole point
that happens all the time wait hold on
so so when we're when we are talking
about where
women women will abuse men and get away
with it and it's really common and
they'll say oh they were the one that
abused me but they don't talk about that
they're doing it too men abuse women and
get away with it there's like
relationships are hard that's what you
always do is you always say but but
because you're trying to make a point
you're trying to make it it's like
you're trying to make a point that's
like women can get away with hitting men
they do and men get away with hitting
women everybody gets rid of hitting each
other haven't you seen those social
experiments where like a man will be
screaming at a woman in public and then
people will stop him and what like
people will stop him and get involved in
whatever and a woman will literally be
beating up a guy in public and nobody
stops nobody does anything if the
question is is who can get away with
abusing their partner in public then I
would agree with you that people tend to
call out men more than women or people
tend to call it yeah however when it
comes because it's not because when
people are abusing each other privately
when it comes time to hold somebody
accountable or responsible it's really
really hard to bring charges against
somebody or go to the police station and
Report anybody who's it harder for men
or women it's probably for either oh
Destiny come on there's a fair amount of
crime that just isn't possible and it's
almost impossible and it was a very
lucrative I can't if yeah if you want to
bring like a legal expert but I can't
argue with like well I had a girl on my
piano and she said that the reality is
that when you go to the police station
report even a rape you can do a full
rape kit if it is only your word against
somebody else's that case dies right
there you can't but you can take
pictures you can like they take pictures
of like um if there's like cuts on them
bruises like it doesn't necessarily mean
you have enough forward it doesn't
necessarily mean that but I'm I'm what
I'm saying is that it's more common for
women to be able to go to the police and
get a conviction versus men going to the
police and getting a conviction for
women but I don't know if that's hold on
there's there's only one way you just
don't go and report it or they back down
there's also a lot going on with what
you just said there to get a conviction
is that's a different type of question
because I mean let me send it
there's even been cases where the a guy
will call the police on a girl and
they'll arrest him you've never seen
those I mean okay a lot of the cases
though the reason why this happens is
because other men are not taking it
seriously the majority of the police
force is still male
Society why it's happened my whole point
is that it's harder for men okay in that
capacity you mentioned get a conviction
okay if men and women are biologically
different if a hundred men attacked 100
women and 100 women attacked 100 men and
everything was perfectly reported and it
was Flawless there was cameras
recordings of everything in that perfect
world wouldn't we still expect more men
to get convicted
because it's more gbh it's because it's
more because it's a bit bigger power
differential right if it if I'm in a if
I I would expect it to be if it's the
same crime equal punishment that's what
I would expect
that if a woman punches
if it's the same who cares about the
damage it's the crime all the damage is
results
so if what about me and dust I'm a
semi-pro athlete so it's like if I punch
Destiny or destiny punches me why would
it not be the same crime why would it
not be the same prosecution
why do women why do women do you want
the actual answer you just want to keep
asking like random questions
why do you want women to get special
treatment gotcha nice loaded question at
the end there the reason why it's a
different crime is because there's
different intentions based on who's
attacking who right if if a 16 year old
girl that weighs 85 pounds starts
running up and slapping me in the face
she's probably not going to be ever like
charged but like she'll get charged with
salt and Battery but it's not going to
be like attempted murder or something
right 250 pound man jumps on a woman and
starts punching her in the face you
might get charged with like attempted
murder or something because the capacity
to do damage there and the state of mind
when you attack the person is going to
be a lot differently if we acknowledge
that there are biological difference
between men and women which I thought we
all agreed on I think we do then there's
going to be a different intent behind a
woman hitting a guy which I agree is
still assaulting battery and I agree he
should still get charged for it and
convicted for it if you do it but the
capacity for damage there shows a
different state of mind than if a man
attacks a woman do you agree that a man
punching someone in the face carries
with it a different intent than a woman
slapping guys excuses okay you have no
comparing his excuses not triggered it's
okay you're just doing this excuses
you're doing the thing the libs are
always giving women excuses it's still
an excuse okay that's cool she's doing
the thing that's right one thing in my
life what thing am I doing a little bit
easier what thing am I doing ignore him
he said anyways he's a trigger you can
make this scenario move even for example
the both using weapons that are the same
then they would be charged this the same
100 then say uh
with the weapon itself like removing the
aspect of the physicality of the human
being you would then charge them based
on the amount of damage that they've
done with that well it depends that when
you're talking about a weapon it depends
on what you're doing right if you shoot
someone in the head of the stomach you
can still charged with like attempted
murder depending what you were trying to
do I mean you know but I'm saying like
how hard is it going to be to like bring
charges like let's say now we go to the
world where we have less perfect
information where I call somebody to the
house 100 men 100 women we have the same
thing we call somebody the house now you
have a house where the guy got slapped
police officers show up and maybe his
face is a little bit red realistically
like what do you can you even do battery
at that point I don't know but if you
show up to the house and then the woman
is there and she's got like a broken jaw
or or her face is like severely [__]
up because the guy hit her well it's
probably going to be easier to charge
the guy there now that's not fair but
again it comes down to like in the court
system like what what can you charge and
like what can you actually the
conviction on and oftentimes I don't
know if women can do enough damage to
men in general I'm not excusing them or
saying it's okay or saying they can stab
them or beat the [__] out of him that's
okay I think that's all horrible but in
general men are going to do more damage
that's going to be more easy to charge I
think do you think that they should be
Char so you don't wait wait sorry so you
don't think they should be charged the
same for doing the same crime
just yes if they do the same crime they
should be charged the same thing so we
agree no we don't agree because I don't
think you know what crime means
the same crime but also same results and
you punch me and I punch you shouldn't
we be charged the same
maybe but that's because you're a you're
a small lady okay if you but if me and
Kelly punch each other there's probably
a different thing oh my gosh so I don't
even get the specials
want special treatment but not for
conservative women true not not for tall
proud volleyball playing conservative
family not for conservative women play
games dude you there's a girl that you
hook up one time right and then she'll
play games then you got to move on to
the next girl whatever like girls are
very fickle and Flaky like she like you
now then her boyfriend hits her but her
ex-boyfriend hits her back up and then
she starts talking to him and she's out
the roster like you girls drop off all
the time I agree kind of but I think
that's because guys play a lot of
[__] games too because guys will run
into girls that are playing games but
it's because they're playing games get
in their DMS oh yeah we can chat like it
was so much fun hanging out with you
like I really enjoyed it like let's hook
up again tonight and then you hook up
you bust and you're like I got [__] I
gotta do in the morning like can you
take off or whatever and then yeah of
course like girls have to play games
because guys are playing the same
[__] game I think if you're upfront
your eyes excusing the women you're
always excusing the women you're like oh
women only play games because of the men
like what
if you want to tell me the
accountability if you want to have a
look at look at it I've I've had guys
play games with me if I play games back
that's on me it's not because of him
you're either someone that plays games
or you're not someone that plays games
you don't have to play play games
because of who you're dating sorry go
ahead go ahead
[Laughter]
if you want to have a healthy view of
the world that allows you to understand
the world well and navigate the world
well that is important to Define what's
healthy sorry go ahead then it's
important to understand why things are
the way they are and then to act
accordingly if you're one of these far
left people and you blame men for
everything then you miss how much dumb
[__] women do cause men to do stupid
things but if you're over on this side
and all you do is blame women for
everything then you miss all the dumb
things that men do that cause women to
act the ways to do so it's good who says
I don't know that men do dumb things
didn't I ask you like two nights ago um
for like what did I ask wasn't it one
question like can you name me something
bad that like uh bad that men do that is
doesn't like involvement then you have
like not a single answer that do you
remember this question
why did you ask I don't I don't remember
I feel it was two nights ago but it
feels like in the Red Bull space every
problem is because of women women are
their standards are too high they're on
Instagram getting flown to do by all the
time and men are like these they're
they're cast as these downtrodden
Warriors that are getting divorced at
ultra high weights from rates from women
and their children are being stolen from
them and they're trying to do these
things they're just like poor men and
it's like no reality is everybody [__]
with everybody everybody's doing dumb
[__] we should hold everybody
accountable we should talk about the
things going on on both sides it's
really dumb and any complicated dating
or relationship interaction to only
analyze one side of things and then say
that it's the only person that's having
the problem
um men do dumb things too are you happy
thank you yeah that's another dumb thing
donation alert but if you do something
dumb you shouldn't blame it on someone
else if you do something dumb that's on
you so if a woman's gonna do dumb [__]
I'm not gonna blame it on the men I'm
gonna say no you you did something dumb
okay that's great but that type of
analysis is pointless you don't need
anybody to say you did something dumb
but the deeper understanding should be
why do people do dumb things did it you
said you just said you just said that
women were playing games because of the
men that is what you said yeah because I
want to understand why are people doing
dumb things not because they chose to do
dumb things that's a stupid of course if
you're I give someone an outcome
that's not an excuse me out to play it
on someone else like why are you with
guys that play games that's on you
somebody might molest kids because they
were molested as a kid that's not an out
that's not an excuse to do it
on this third party extreme example this
is like the Abu now he's gonna bring up
child molestation when we're talking
about games it's like all right let's
skip to the end
she's like I have better things to do
and you're like yo you wanna that's all
I'm into that's all I'm looking for
whatever and she said they're like yeah
sure or no
that will that that's it like don't all
say that is absolutely nothing
if you're clouded up on [__] YouTube
it doesn't work man you girls want your
time they don't want they don't want
easy sex we want also if you want to
roast Destiny I'm gonna read all the
super chats that roast him and none of
the ones from his fans that are roasting
me way to make money yeah so feel free
the first one to send I don't know
a high Super Chat you know you can
decide what's high I'll read the roast
live
they want our time I feel like don't
give out bad advice a minute tell them
to say it's not no no it's not advice to
normal men it's advice to clouded guys
which is what you guys talk about next
week I've never said wanna [__] do you
want to bet right now that you couldn't
go into your Instagram DMs I know you
could find it yeah and a girl's hitting
you up okay do you want to hook up there
are girls on this panel that you can
[__] tonight that's with little to no
effort
Destiny easy I get what you're saying
but at the same time it's a numbers game
like I'm saying yes it's one thing
actually showing up not saying I don't
know how I feel about this can we go on
a date like they're gonna change because
it's the guys trying to [__] it up don't
do anything creepy don't do anything
[__] weird
[__] it up it's usually not that hard to
land Destiny I can tell you have no
experience
I can't believe you said that why did
you throw it away why did you throw them
all under the bus but all these women
would [__] you as well because it's true
unless you're that's why I don't I don't
want to talk [__] what no go ahead go
ahead go talk [__] talk [__] if you are
a decently clouded guy you should be
able to get no strings attached to sex
from random people that's just a fact
yeah that's true but these guys say that
they can't none of them can do it look
at something but you're looking at like
top like what percent of cloud are they
in that's what no no but that was my
point but they're but they're saying
like sneako look they're saying sneako
and Myron couldn't just [__] a girl no
strings attached maybe they have like
really little I mean I just feel like no
man has Heist that's not that's a myth
that men say on the internet to make
them feel better about them and they
don't know how do you know do they [__]
whales on the sign of this one never say
anything about that I didn't say
anything I didn't say any of that hello
where is King riches he would agree with
me he said the same thing two nights
okay there's a there's a roast of you oh
okay go ahead Destiny you're the little
bro that sides with Mom during the
divorce even though she broke up the
family cheated and Etc wow I have
another one I hope she had a college
degree don't roast me because I'm not
gonna read it Destiny is the NPC in a
video game that is below the signif the
level of significance of the main
character also you can't roast her I
won't read it wow yeah you can I don't
mind I'm sorry
there are like 20 girls right now that I
could fly out if I wanted to tonight and
never see them again and they'd be
totally cool with it but that's because
I'm super up front right at the start
when I talk to people I'm [__]
married I'm never [__] dating you but
like we could be friends oh my God I'll
chill we can do it and I know there are
other guys that are super clouded up on
YouTube that can do it as well but when
you guys are planning these weird how
many girls in each City could you do
that with that are like decently
attractive like no whales don't count no
like sub thought like like cute cute
enough
in each City
this is a lose-lose conversation for me
because it's because it's going to look
like it's gonna it's just weird I'm not
saying you would I'm saying could I'm
just curious I'm a decently famous
person I think there's a person that's
decently attractive that I could
probably have sex with any City it's a
fan of mine
but that but but that
all right absolutely that's gonna be
true anyway
big function of being like
clouded guys get a lot of [__] well but
these guys
that are in your DMs listening I'm just
a little bit I'm just curious yeah well
I will say though the girls that I tend
to hang out with though can also be kind
of [__] insane so but yeah I know
through I'm not but that's okay you know
I'm sorry
oh like you're trying to like maneuver
or do [__] RIS or whatever just be up
front be honestly don't be creepy
Destiny today she's with you then she's
with me and him it can bear you we're
just saying okay in slow night you're
chilling with the boys she's available
all right good to go where'd they say
live bro
I'm gonna be very simple about this the
1970s there was a study done where when
women were straight up proposition for
sex it was a 95 failure now let's go
ahead and status and clout to it okay
that might lower the chance to maybe a
90 or an 85 based on who the guy is but
you got to understand that there's
multiple points of failure when you deal
with a woman for sure hey Wanna [__]
sure next day changes I don't know how I
feel about this and then she then she
comes over to your place do you mind if
we go on a date oh no oh like girls
change their mind based off how they
feel that's true do you agree with this
did you hear that that's like a cold
feet example I half agree but it's
because they're probably [__] it up
maybe maybe well I mean but you see your
eyes putting it on the men it also could
be like we're at a different point on
our cycle and we just don't feel like it
because I might can I it might let me
know when you're done and I'll explain
how this transaction works I'm gonna
give you I'm gonna time you okay ready
hold on not not yet calculate I would be
way too anxious to just [__] someone
over Instagram trims that's fine people
terrify me know how to get the timer off
caught up in a suitcase oh I'm ready
okay go ahead okay women tend to have
more at risk and a hookup than a guy
does the woman has decided that she
wants to [__] you that's conditional on
everything going right now as long as
you don't do anything creepy weird
stupid rapey or whatever generally you
can bring things home but if the girl
comes over and your place looks weird or
you act weird or you're too touchy or
you push too much you make a creepy joke
or something is off there's a lot of
chance you can lose at that point in the
interaction So when you say women change
your mind a lot I guess they can but I
feel like some guys make it seem like
randomly like one like oh well I don't
want to [__] you now because the [__]
moon is not in the [__] Sagittarius
passion when a reality Chancellor you
probably did something to mess it up
um time 30 seconds 35 I was 30 you took
five seconds
I'll give you 32. 34.
um I think you're partially wait wait
wait wait wait wait don't answer it hold
on I'm gonna time you now
it's crazy I don't talk as much as you I
don't you know what's crazy
and then he was like don't interrupt me
and I was just like he had been talking
the whole time I watched the video back
whole time
um see I don't like the timer no keep
going were you gonna respond to my point
no okay I agree with you partially that
sometimes the guys mess it up but also
it's based on how we feel and sometimes
random things that make no sense mess it
up and it's nothing to do with the guy
okay 21 seconds yeah see always less
than you what was what is a random thing
the point we're getting here there can
be a lot of variables that's true so
what is a random thing that messed it up
um they're not over somebody else and
they get cold feet yeah that's actually
really true so that's that's something
yeah
your ex texts you
okay I mean you asked for a variable
there you go so that has nothing to do
with you that would have nothing to do
with the guy that's not the guy messing
it up in any way
but a girl's like X could text her and
then she's like oh maybe
I guess I've never had that happen in my
life I guess that you know but you don't
know why the girl's saying no and like a
lot of times there's reasons like guys
don't even know
okay I
disagreement they're a little bit
different than probably the ones that
you talk to right so that might be why
you're yeah maybe it's very true because
I'm up front Okay that's why I'm not
playing games yeah sure okay they don't
want to feel like so if you say what the
[__] she might say yes up front then
when it's time to actually do it she
changes her mind so what I'm saying is
that there's multiple points of failure
when you deal with a girl girls flake a
lot girls I'm curious have you guys ever
there's three guys in here have you guys
ever had a girl yeah I'm asking everyone
have you ever had a girl sleep in your
bed and not do anything with you
yeah it's happened yeah yeah so you
wouldn't say that's like a girl changing
your mind last minute
um no she can't I'm not saying it's
impossible no yeah but so that's that's
what he's saying I think and it's kind
of validated by the fact that everyone
in here that's happened too no what I'm
disagreeing with is I don't think it's
like a random thing I think you have a
lot of control over it as a guy that
doesn't mean it's gonna be 100
um
do you think it's random
random
I think a lot of women won't necessarily
be confident with someone that they've
literally just met so I mean that you
could know them I didn't ask any of them
how long they knew the girl
um yep but if if we're talking like this
is a hookup so I mean if you've known
them longer especially friends they're
more likely to be like yes than if we're
just dming someone because I think the
the context is them being DMV random
girls on Instagram yeah so there is the
potentiality for that to just
them get cold feet change their mind
feel this way they feel that way a guy
hits them up boyfriends them up they're
on their period there's so many
different uh variables that could come
in that bucket up for you now I get what
you're saying yo just proposition them
be honest with them that doesn't work
for most guys sure I'll say the you'd
agree with that right that won't work
yeah I've never said last thing I'll say
and you can do whatever it is I agree
with you that women will play games but
more often than not just from the DMS
that I've seen from the people women and
men that I talk to it's usually because
the guys are playing games too if you're
up front you make a shutdown immediately
what do you mean by like the guy what
games are the guy is playing so
oftentimes women are trying to select
for people that aren't just for an
immediate hookup so the games that guys
play as they try to present themselves
as something that's not just looking to
hook up but they are and then as soon as
they get it then they disappear
so like if I'm hitting up people when I
was in California when I was on Tinder
more or if I'm chatting the person I'm
usually pretty upfront that like I'm
looking for something casual very maybe
very short term maybe just a hookup and
then like they're either into it or
they're not and then we figure it out
from there but if you start like oh like
I really like your pictures I think
you're really cool and blah blah blah
and then you do all this and you hook up
and then you like disappear you're like
playing a game yeah I think that saying
I like your pictures is playing a game
are you
I'm getting sucked in because of how
dense you're collapsing into a black
hole because of how dense you have to be
to have taken from that whole
explanation that all I was saying was
saying you like your pictures and
leading somebody on I'm sorry oh my God
you're about to collapse into a black
hole
I was just thinking that I was just
thinking that this bar is pretty low for
a game if the games if that was the only
thing I said Pearl I would agree with
you oh my God that was a low bar Big Ups
big upset bar for playing yeah
get on the internet a lot longer than me
so I think there's like things that you
say that I just don't understand that's
a London phrase right there no big UPS
don't do that King Richard said it like
20 times
oh my God how many of these do we have
how long is this one it wouldn't be so
long if you'd shut the [__] up
Jesus Christ
that's why I didn't want her to come on
that's why I told her to knock him
yesterday okay okay
can I come on your Twitch stream oh yeah
you guys might have so much fun she does
this thing it's called body painting you
would love it okay body painting oh you
got you can do it together it would be
so cute
you'll love it it's so good I'm not
gonna like it you'll love it a little
bit of a differentiation it'll be really
good fine fine oh did she commit it to
it you heard it guys good luck on that
fine I won't go on no no she doesn't
seem to want to oh no no it's okay it'll
be fun don't worry no I don't I didn't
know the bottom I thought she was just a
streamless
I'm trying to click it it's not going
there are people on the right that are
willing to speak some uneasy truths that
people on the left just won't
acknowledge and as long as you're not
willing to acknowledge something it's
true you're going to lose to the people
that I just like to say defending
conservatives once again wow Destiny
always defending College what's true I
think that red pillars will make some
observations that are true and then they
get wild with it and they go off into
these crazy places where it's like I
understand where you're starting from
but the places that you go you could go
in such a better direction is Andrew
Tate good for for the guys or not I'd
say absolutely not I think that the idea
of masculinity and success and
fulfillment that's being sold by a lot
of people on the right I think leads to
the same type of spiritual Wasteland
that you're trying to like pull these
young men out of I would say like when I
look at somebody like Andrew Tate or
even like for you guys or anybody that
talks about red pill stuff it always
feels like you're big markers for
Success are how many women can you get
how much money can you make what kind of
cars do you drive and at the end of the
day I just I don't know how old you guys
are but like when I think back to the
things I've had in my life like I don't
like remember the third you know new
iPhone I got I don't remember like when
I got my new car like it was cool for
like a week but like there are memories
that you make with other people there
are things that you achieve or
accomplish in your life for Me Maybe
stuff related to music maybe stuff
related to gaming when I was in Esports
like these are the standout memories
that I have but I never hear anybody in
like the red pill Society building
towards that it always feels like
they're building towards like the most
hollowed existence that you possibly
could have as a man that gets like
signed off by mainstream consumer
Society you've applied that a lot to me
but I've never even really talked about
that and even if I do I want the ability
to buy those things it's not those
things are going to make me happy I just
want to have the power tell them sneako
or to not be restricted by anything but
I guess the argument Big Ups to sneako
Big Ups I'm with the signs
I want to be rich Niko is out here
speaking facts dunking on Destiny big
point I always make is if you spend all
of your life trying to get the
capability to have everything right like
a man who spends his whole life on the
mission once that mission is fulfilled
he has nothing because your whole life
you've just spent trying to get stuff
right and you haven't worked on building
relationships building friendships
accomplishing something real the best
type of advice you get from red pill is
at least working out as long as you're
doing it for yourself and not to impress
a chick but like because building your
body means something right you don't
prove something you get money I don't
know I don't think that's that important
I think that there are like upgrades to
your life you can make if you're making
15 000 a year and you live with your mom
and dad yeah you need to up your money
of course but like if you've got a
decent job and I've seen this as a
millennial there's a lot of people from
my generation who are sitting in their
apartment making 140 000 a year doing
work from home who hate themselves they
have no friends except for the ones that
they see light up on Discord they have
no Hobbies except for the 4 000th game
of League of Legends they play for the
day and they have like no fulfillment in
their life they have nothing and these
are the types of people no also
why do you let that Destiny talk so much
Pro why do you let that Destiny talk so
much you just talk for like two minutes
and you didn't say anything because I
felt like you were tied on time like I
felt like you've been sitting oh my God
oh my God I was trying to get the video
in the videos okay the video go you're
doing a good job farming over there
Kelly congratulations okay what is
farming she's farming right now what
does farming mean she's saying she's
saying things that she knows again or
brownie points with the audience or with
you she's farming okay
a lot of League of Legends as well right
yes
we're both uh survivors she's doing a
good job I'm on her team okay yeah like
how do I meet girls how do I meet
friends like why is it that I've hit
every big marker in my life but I'm
miserable and I think that that void
isn't being answered by anybody I think
right now so Destiny do you believe in
the hero's journey like the Greek
archetype or whatever yeah I mean I
believe it's a story and to some extent
it's applicable to our lives yeah of
course so to me from what I see Andrew
doing he's giving you the hero story
he's been through hardship you know or
not successful he worked his way up he
said you know what speaking facts fresh
well if I could scan this way to the top
yeah how did he scan his way to the top
his whole business was scamming men
what what do you what do you mean
camming that whole business was scamming
men Oh I thought you're talking about
fresh oh no I was talking about he's
talking about Andrew Tate about
oh scamming your way to the top well you
can too as well would you agree on that
or no with these guys okay these guys
are on the Titanic and there's one
Lifeboat that can hold 400 people and
there's 10 000 people on the deck and
they're like everybody can get in this
boat that's not true anybody could get
in the boat but not all 10 000 of them
were getting in okay when you've got
like a podcast where guys are talking
about don't you think we should strive
to get in the boat like you should tell
people to strive for it doesn't mean
everyone will get it I think we should
probably teach people to swim
what
I don't get it I'm sorry I think
accepting the circumstances you're in
teaching everybody to swim would
probably be better than trying to get 10
000 people and afford a person Lifeboat
teach people how to deal with life as it
comes rather than saying you could be
the exceptional one percent because 99
of people are going to meet that market
why wouldn't you tell people to like do
what you did because most of them fail
you're the exception yeah but I
understand that yeah but not everybody
can yeah but I think I think everybody
can find something that contributes to
society and they can do well at it yeah
but not all of those jobs are going to
be highly like uh compensated
you're going to be exceptionally
depressed if you failed
um it's good to have a reason but that
doesn't mean you can't push yourself
I think I think you do anything
I like genuinely believe I can do
anything
that's that it must be what a fun
background you know no yeah
I'm serious I just don't understand I
believe you I believe you feel that way
I don't understand in the position
you're in why you wouldn't encourage
people to get into your position it's
like he wants to be the only one in the
position
because disappointment comes in your
life when you have a difference between
the expectation and the reality of a
situation if you're selling somebody
that you want to try to be the next big
YouTuber the next big star do you know
how many people buy like the brand new
computers the brand new overlays they
get all their stuff set up and then they
stream for like six months to two
viewers
like it's not healthy to put somebody in
a state of mind where like you have to
go for the top one percent or else
you're nothing you're a loser you
haven't made it it's better to teach
people like how can you excel at areas
in life that will make you happy you
don't need to be like a massive
Superstar but I'm saying it doesn't mean
they'll get to where you get but taking
advice from you could help them get
there maybe they don't get I don't know
how many followers you had on Twitch or
famous generally not considered a
something that people strive to for but
they think other people strive for and
it can kind of you don't think people
strive for fame I think a lot less
people do than the people that think
others all want it it's the least thing
that people actually end up wanting but
obviously with Fame there comes money
and other things you get from it but the
actual things but my whole my whole
point is that he's in a position a lot
of people would want to be in like
you're successful like you have you've
been on the internet for 10 years like
that's a huge accomplishment 12 years
but okay no I'm serious so many people
come and go even like when you're here
I'm asking you questions because I think
it's cool how long you've been on the
internet like not a lot of people can do
that I think so I just would not like I
just stress here
I understand he's a special person I
understand that too but I'm saying like
why wouldn't you want to encourage
people to get to where you're at because
I feel like you're going to keep asking
me this is so exceptional at it you're
gonna keep asking me the same question
because you don't like the answer to me
but I'll say it again if I have a
hundred thousand people listening and I
give tips on how to reach my position
maybe 20 or 30 of them maybe could like
hit something similar why would I do
that instead of talking to all 100 000
we're like here are things that you
could do to have a happier life like I
feel like I'd rather do that because
realistically not everybody could be in
the top one percent of every industry or
whatever right yeah but it's like you
may they might not hit where you've hit
but they could still improve from where
they're at no
no no okay okay they're it for being a
streamer
there it's a little bit of a binary you
either make it or you don't if somebody
puts aside like six months of their life
to try to get into streaming and they
don't get more than two viewers it's not
like oh well at least I improved myself
a ton because I was like on the journey
like there's no Journey it's like going
for like professional sports right if
you throw your whole life into
volleyball or basketball or whatever and
it doesn't work out and you don't even
get like good you know like NCAA spots
well I mean like what do you have to
show for it's like well you know at
least I was on the journey like well no
now it's like okay I need to go back and
like figure out what I actually do with
my life now right I mean you still have
skills a little bit but it's like but
but you could have been building in so
many other ways right I think it's
better to have like a solid foundation
for a life so some type of like decent
job that gives you money and then from
there build out the things that we know
make people happy have a good sleep
schedule have a good diet get a little
bit of exercise and have like
friendships reptile encourages all of
that that like the self-improvement
stuff like they encourage them to have a
good sleep schedule have a good diet go
to the gym like and you agreed with that
earlier I but it feels like the
self-improvement has a vein angle to it
all the time and that's the issue right
you don't like the vein the vanity I
don't get it because the vanity is a
different type of improvement right like
you could see people that get lost in
certain things they get obsessive over
certain things because they didn't chase
it for the right reason right if you're
working on these four pillars because
you want to make yourself into a happy
healthy person that's fine but if you're
doing this because you hope you get a
Bugatti in 10 years it's it's got it
takes on a different character well I
don't understand why that's a bad thing
to want to get a Bugatti because of your
life I under I kind of understand where
you're coming from in a way because like
like my parents were always more I mean
we always had nice like houses or
whatever but like they weren't into
designer clothes we weren't into like
typically like rich like my dad drove
the same car for 20 years like I
understand like modesty with that stuff
but at the same time like if you're
gonna tell a 20 year old kid just try to
get a Bugatti I just don't see anything
wrong with that because things don't
make you happy in a fulfilling sense
nobody's bought a thing that's made them
happy for a long time things make you
happy for days or maybe a couple weeks
very short term but if you're building
on like friendships and relationships
some of those things will last for your
entire life and it just feels weird to
me that in a way there go ahead
experiences too go ahead go ahead I'm
sorry
in a way like I think the hyper liberal
attitude of the West has driven people
into a sort of like spiritual kind of
like destitution to where people feel
like they don't have very much meaning
or purpose in life and part of that I
think can be laid on the doorstep of
capitalism or more specifically hyper
consumerism buy this phone buy this
watch buy this car and red pillars have
correctly identified that there's a lot
of like purposeless like men that don't
feel like they have much going on in
life but then they take them and they
you know they they do some weird
calculus to throw them right back into
that rat race of like okay now that
you're here okay forget these liberal
loser World Order guys or whatever we're
gonna have you guys going to the gym and
getting ripped and getting so you can
get [__] and get money so you can get a
lot of cars I was like that's like the
same Capital [__] you just left behind
right especially with those guys talk
about capitalism is has a political
leaning right there's plenty of liberals
that have lots of expense things well
sure but I'm just saying that like um
because of capitalism yeah and
capitalism the goal is just cellular
things with materialism is a good thing
yeah but but you can argue that a
capitalistic mindset drives like a hyper
consumer is hyper materialist mindset
right
here's how you become a millionaire
doing this without that yeah maybe
there's like some percentage your
audience could do it but 98 of these
guys are going to fail and we everybody
knows that from the dawn of any
multi-level marketing any online type of
advertising any like encouragement to
like get rich doing these things like
these goals are for 98 of people totally
unattainable can anybody do it probably
can everybody do it absolutely not a lot
of people you say can anybody do it
probably oh so you kind of anyone can do
it
he he just he contradicted himself I
think he means so anyone can try but the
majority will not succeed I think good
job Kelly yeah
so anyone can do it I think that anyone
can okay
on the left for whatever dumb [__]
reason are really scared of
self-improvement like I'm reading
articles from The New York Times saying
that like you know workout culture has
been taken over by the right at least he
realizes there's a bunch of weirdos on
the left
yeah thank you I appreciate that with
the right have a monopoly on improving
your body what a stupid thing meanwhile
I go to the left and I'm seeing like
Health at every side [__] I'm like oh
well that's why me I guess you know I
genuinely wholeheartedly believe if
you're a fat it's your [__] fault and
you deserve zero sympathy the thing
thank you Myron I agree
at number 15. let's go there are also
medical illnesses but they genuinely
call us
what a smart guy this is it like the
core of that messaging is correct
because of their poor choices you should
love it because of the genetics and the
hormonal or their poor choices fighter
no I'm saying for the people that are
medically are you gonna let her get away
with that what I mean Diabetes Type 1
for example is like an auto Moon and
disease and you can't control autoimmune
disease okay but she's gonna talk about
the exception rather than the rule yeah
yeah no I'm only talking about people
with actual movies okay I'll give you
like half a percent of the population
I'll give you point zero you think only
half of the percentage of the population
has diabetes uh base yes and that should
be the big drive to improve it even if
you are overweight you can still love
yourself you don't have to hate yourself
and that should be like the big drive
that's pushing you
you should hate yourself a little bit
back towards being a healthy person but
somehow somewhere along the way that got
convoluted or warped into well you're
healthy and you love yourself and we
can't be having any problems with
ourselves we love ourselves so if you
love yourself nothing can be wrong with
you therefore you're perfect the way you
are and then don't work on anything and
that's what's happened with so many of
these left-leaning narratives is that
they also send super chats to roast
Destiny at the end I guess kind of like
the right ones where like the central
idea I think is good those reasons for
why people are in the areas they are
suddenly become justifications or
rationalizations to never improve
anything agree and yeah now the
explainer for why you are where you are
has become the handicap of the crutch
that's preventing you from succeeding
there's a quote just because one side
airs too far does it really follow that
the other side couldn't be airing too
far as well and that's kind of how I
feel it like the left is right away for
sure but that doesn't mean that the
right has the correct answer you're in
the middle if you were born middle class
and you're middle class your whole life
you didn't accomplish you showed up to
life every day and you did fine you went
to school you went to college and you
got a job and that's great but those
same people that started middle class
and ended up middle class we'll look at
people that are lower class and these
people will stay lower class and they'll
look down on them and it's like why hold
on you didn't improve your lot in life
at all do you think that people that
start lower class and get to upper class
have a right to look down on Lower Class
people because they came from it and did
it I don't think you should look down on
anyone okay but would you say no okay so
no one can look down at anyone you don't
look down on anyone never never because
I'm so sure that's a bit I feel like
everyone looks down on people yeah not
me okay I'm a saint are you lying right
now no I'm not lying like this is the
man that was bullying me
oh you stayed the same the whole time
why would you look down at a guy you
know who's making 24K a year who came
from a family of people making 24K a
year it's not like you're a millionaire
now and you had every right to be right
because if you were born middle class in
America in the United States of America
the [__] world is at your fingertips
people on the right will I agree you do
have the world at your fingertips but
I'm making the bad argument you're
agreeing with a bad argument that I'm
making being born in America being born
in America you have so much opportunity
then why did you come to the UK to get
rich I actually no I didn't mean to I
don't know
careful careful did you hear that I'm
sorry I don't like the UK um I I came
here to play volleyball that's where I
came and then I started it and
everything blew up I was supposed to
that's I was supposed to move to Germany
volleyball stupid like yeah I think
family is really important and you know
like my grandpa my great grandpa and
[__] like you know the contributions
they made to my parents that really
helped me in life and then they'll turn
around and say some [__] like I don't
think Jim Crow matters that was in the
60s like bro this family doesn't have a
[__] house because they want a lot to
live in this part but we're not saying
that a lot of stuff has changed in the
world with regard to technology
everybody in the left wants to blame
like the patriarchy and racism and then
people on the right want to blame
feminization of men or feminism or
whatever I think that a lot of our lives
have fundamentally changed in ways that
people aren't even aware of in an
incredibly short amount of time when I
was in school and Facebook came out back
then online only existed to augment your
real life but at some point past 15
years in real life it became real life I
don't use Facebook or Discord to connect
with real-life friends I use Facebook
and descript to get friends that's not
the same thing but because it plays into
these like really bad I don't really
remember much of the world before social
media
how old are you in 25 26 26 okay I think
when I was in high school is when
Facebook started to Branch out to
non-harvard email addresses I was born
in 88 so yeah basically the early
Facebook the only there were four tabs
on it I remember what all four were was
like messages groups or places or
something else and then your wall um I
don't know if they have any of these
things anymore but the only thing you
would use Facebook for when I was in
school was checking into parties that's
what everybody used it for I got it in
eighth grade and it was the first time I
realized I wasn't invited to something I
was like what I have a question I got a
product that just went past like what do
they mean when they say the feminization
of men oh no don't do it
now I'm just curious what is the
definition of this it's not really a
definite it's like men today act like
women in which ways oh no no I'm just
curious because it's something I don't
understand because it gets talked about
a lot and I just stare at the wall and
I'm like I'm confused by what this means
which way is
um it's just like I don't know men today
act like women so it's like even in
their language in in
I don't know like the way they talk and
stuff
really
um okay
I say evolutionary traps make us feel
good we keep pursuing it even more a
really good example of this I think work
from home is probably a really bad idea
that being locked in your room like
doing your work on your computer screen
you like you wake up you're working then
you get off and you play The League of
Legends and you talk to people on
Discord and then you go to sleep and you
repeat that for 365 days that has to rot
the mind more than feminism more than
patriarchy more than anything else
technology has it's hurt men and
benefited women now with the Advent of
Instagram the Advent of online you don't
agree with that
just everything in the world helped
women and everything in the world hurt
me it sounds like men are [__]
children that's what it sounds like
no I think that technology has probably
helped everybody and hurt everybody in a
lot of different ways that we're still
like for instance he brings up it's I
don't even think I brought this on the
show but he brings up Instagram I'm
pretty sure social media is like some of
the most damaging stuff for young girls
in middle school and high school because
of how much like information they're
bombarded with in terms of beauty
standards how they look that's like been
an extremely detrimental thing that I
think is pretty well stated at this
point
but you guys are like well but Instagram
helps them get flown out to Dubai so I
think like yeah it does yeah it's like
totally you're totally disconnected from
like the real world I mean
I mean it also lets you catfish the hell
out of men like with these freaking
Instagram filters oh my God you know
many girls come on the show and then
they're gonna make fun of me Pearl just
talks about the girls of the show I
don't know what to tell you where it's
like I'll look at their Instagram they
look completely different like how are
you gonna complain about beauty
standards if like you're changing your
face online yeah but even that that like
who's getting catfished more there men
or other women
men are they because that's the issue
right it's because like young girls are
looking at that stuff on Instagram and
they think that's what a woman looks
like oh they know because my little
sister I don't edit pictures on
Instagram I don't know how in all
honesty but like my my sister when she's
like going through Instagram and stuff
she'll be the first to say like nobody
she doesn't look like that because they
all do it so they all know yeah but
they're all trying to fit that beauty
standard if that's all you see if you're
bombarded with this image I don't know
what to tell you this is just like
objectively true like people evaluate
their beauty status based on the media
that they consume and the thing emerges
around them like that's just absolutely
true freaking who I mean even without
Photoshop my relatives people pick their
best photos Ryan the best lighting then
why don't you say boohuda guy's getting
catfished
guy man they're just not good at taking
pictures of themselves yeah and then she
get better at catfishing and they should
know when women are using filters
I mean they they probably should I mean
I think men do know that's the crazy
thing they do know okay then we're not
getting catfish we're all just making
[__] up for each other I mean I
think you you know when you get I mean
come on you know when you get on the
Tinder date and it's like who is this I
well I know now I've learned my lesson
yeah cheating apps women get more
opportunities now than ever before so
what happens is is that a majority of
men now aren't even considered as
suitable candidates what's happened is
you know you think that's true like okay
is women have stepped into more and more
traditionally masculine roles they're
earning more money they're handling
they're stable there's more to them than
just looking pretty but men are not
allowed to step in traditionally
feminine roles now they've taken the
masculine role of like hold on I got a
career I'm working I'm smart I get to
handle my okay cool well can I just like
be somebody like take care of the
household like let me like cooking clean
no you're a [__] loser wait hold on
but that's what you did 40 years ago but
now that women have stepped into the
mask and roll they're looking at all
these men and you know studies show this
women are earning more and more and more
and more but they still won't date down
so economically they still won't date a
poor guy I was like well hold on if you
are a man and you find a woman
oftentimes this is going to be the first
person you can actually connect with on
an emotional level in your entire
[__] life because you don't connect
like that with your Bros you don't
connect like that with guys you have
conversations she doesn't need a man for
that emotional connection she can get a
lot of emotional connections from her
friend group I want to say like 38 or 37
of women are okay being single one of
the reasons why that happens and this is
where I will attack a lot of like the
hyper masculine stuff that red pill cell
is men are horrible friends to each
other when you listen to two women talk
she might go through some and she's like
man I got this going on this is how I
feel about this and they're talking to
each other bouncing their feelings up
they have like these they have they have
these really rich and fulfilling
friendships with each other women yes
they I'm curious do the guys do the guys
in the room do you think that's true
like men are bad friends to each other
no he doesn't it's true absolutely
I'm just curious do you guys like you
don't so you talk about your problems to
your guy friends no I think men
generally don't share those types of
problems no you don't no you don't do it
not nowhere near to the extent that
women do okay but you think we it should
be an equal extent I think that women do
it so like if women if I have five
problems a day I share with my friends
how many should men do if if you're
gonna make it like a hyper autistic like
do I share every single like when my
shoes don't fit blah blah blah no but I
think that women that's rude I don't
know what sharing five problems I don't
understand five problems a day means
you're not engaging in my question like
if you would be I just want to know when
it you would be happy with the amount of
problems men would share if you have a
significant problem in your life that it
would enrich yourself to get feedback
from from your friends then it's good to
communicate that problem do you mean men
on average struggle yes but see this is
like what I'm what I talked about
earlier the feminization of men he's
doing it because he's trying to tell men
to communicate like women
because I think women oh oh there I just
showed it I just showed it boom can I
get an edit but I feel like you can
communicate without necessarily being
like women do you mean like overly
emotional and crying no no wait wait
wait Pearl do you think that less men
should commit suicide
yes why are you trying to feminize men
you're trying to make men like women
where men don't commit seriously
[Music]
oh my God this is his debate test he's a
debater it's like it's like we'll be
talking about A and B and he'll bring up
point six bro not a good look for you so
far he's brought up not a good look for
you that Pearl sorry oh my God he's
brought up suicide he's brought up child
molestation and abuse it's like yeah why
did they laugh like this is what the
lefties they'll do they'll bring up
these random points that have nothing to
do with what we're talking about nothing
to do I think maybe it's better to put
it like um foreign
like men can open up without being
overly emotional right I think that's
usually I don't think anybody should be
overly emotional men or women no yeah of
course but I think maybe men are a bit
too much closed off because I mean isn't
a talking point of red pill sort of like
no one listens to men no one cares about
men but usually isn't that because men
don't care about men true
so I think that's what he was trying to
get at before he went absolutely true
absolutely can you explain that again I
don't get it
yeah well at least the talking points
I've seen it's like people don't care
about men's feelings that's why they
commit so when I when I say people are
talking about society as a whole doesn't
care about men's issues who's Society
aren't there like two types of people
you feel like women on men
um yeah um yeah I mean I would say men
have more empathy to men's problems than
women do
um however I would say it's on both
sides yes
I don't know I don't know which question
you answered
I'm just saying that like it feels like
if it's it would seem strange that we
have a societal epidemic of people not
listening to men if all men were
listening to men feels like that's
probably something I said I think that
yeah no I think that men also don't
listen to men's problems at times too
like you okay
mother
might be ready to kill himself and he's
like John what's up he's like nothing
much man how are you doing yeah you know
and then like like it's like what the
[__] is happening guys suck at talking
to each other we do the emotional
connection that we have with each other
absolutely abysmal but guys are so dumb
they'll sit there in the friend zone for
decades and give away free attention and
get used and not even understand their
value it is so socially acceptable to
talk about power dynamics and
relationships when they benefit the man
nobody talks about them when they
benefit the women that really bothers me
like everybody will talk about see he's
on our side now Zone you know that girl
wants to date you and here you are just
having sex with you that's manipulative
you're a piece of [__] and then it's
like oh okay well you've got this guy
that you've got given you like wake-up
calls on Saturday Sunday morning that
you wouldn't touch with a 10-foot pole
okay and this guy like walks your dog
like how are you not abusing the [__]
out of this dude if anything at the very
least Zone girls are just getting
physically this guy's soul is getting by
you okay you are rotting this man from
the inside out let him this is the first
time you've seen you speak facts go okay
free this poor man from his like
servitude because holy how important is
freedom to you and why I don't think
freedom is very important to many people
at all I think people like the idea of
freedom there's an interesting book
there's going on that's called the
Paradox of choice the reality is when
you actually put more choices in front
of people they actually get more
stressed out about picking the wrong
thing yes facts they did that ice cream
flavor you can even feel that if you go
to a restaurant and they give you a menu
with like 50 things that's some
stressful like people want to be able to
pursue the things that make them happy
that doesn't always mean you need to be
able to choose between 500 things
sometimes it does but not usually I
think people just want to be able to
carve out paths in their life you need
the freedom to be able to choose like
the job that you want or like to be able
to have a family or to raise kids or or
that type of thing so I don't think that
having a ton of freedom is necessarily
the most important thing but you at
least have to feel like you have the
freedom to make the choices you want
femininity and masculinity should be
balanced in every person right like even
your hormones like men produce some
estrogen women produce some testosterone
like like it's part of you that you
should be able to as a strong man have
some feminine traits or as a strong
woman have some masculine trades like I
think it's good to be balanced I think
when you shut off those things
completely because you think that like
being a man means you have to be the
most extreme unemotional person ever
that's you get people coming back from
like Vietnam or Iraq that are like PTSD
to the [__] brand because they feel
like they can't open up or talk to
anybody about anything I think that it
is a weakness as a man to be unable to
like address or handle or deal with your
feelings in an open and honest manner to
not be able to do that and I feel like
you've got to lock everything down and
not process those things I think that's
a person that has a weakness that they
need to address I agree I think the only
thing is is that you need to open it
with other men that understand your uh
struggle and your experience that's
another reason too do you clip him
saying I agree
um for like yourself I don't know what
channel is this not a fan of opening up
to women this yeah I'm curious it says
fresh and fit no I don't this seems this
is this like accomplishment of me right
you definitely have sympathy
I don't know because they don't
understand the middle experience and not
only do they not understand the mail
Express they don't give a [__] about
them experience they've come on this
podcast if we've had discussions about
this most women don't even know that
like one-third of guys is either a
virgin or hasn't had sex in the past
year but I will say on the flip side too
guys are holy brain dead when it comes
to understanding some of the fears or
struggles that women have sometimes too
right yeah guys will say stupid you're
like oh like I'm meeting him for a state
why can't I just pick you up from your
house like why can't you just come back
to my place or whatever it's like bro
you weigh 80 pounds heavier this home
you could [__] it's instant if you
wanted to
what who which channel is this I'm just
curious
and on a good rape analogy I mean uh
whatever you say instead grape analogy
sorry
what is the channel I can't read it I
can't what does it say King brain rot oh
brain run politics I need to hire that
guy that guy he's awesome yeah I know
he's my will I need to employ that dude
brain right politics you have a job
offer from Destiny well he'll he'll
he'll pay you a lot because he's a lib
wow
um what a day what a day I I had fun
did you have fun I had so much fun did
you have fun are we always have fun are
we best friends best friends oh until
you get mad at me yeah sure
it'll happen it'll come don't worry it's
already starting I feel well you seem
like the common denominator in all these
situations I am people get real mad at
me it's all good oh okay but hey my arms
are open to everybody I love the world
it's probably your fault uh okay
would you do you think it's his fault
I think he's a very acquired taste of a
human being but hey we have known each
other for ages yeah you haven't tried to
kill each other yet no there was like a
three year period where we didn't talk
but you know it happens why did you have
being around well you hadn't fallen out
I just [__] wasn't on the internet oh
that's true yeah we stopped playing
again yeah there was no League of
Legends anymore thank you for coming I'm
on your team we're on the same side
we're on the same side yeah I look
forward to seeing you guys doing the
body painting stream together I don't
really understand what body painting is
but I just don't it's best not to know
it's fine it's let's see uh okay
um
um okay guys shout out your channels one
more time if you want hi I'm youtube.com
Destiny and you can find me at
instagram.com Destiny
um I'm Kelly Jean I'm probably not your
acquired content but hey it's nice to
know y'all I mean I I think they would
like the body painting yeah give us one
one social something where can we find
you at okay
okay guys like the video on your way oh
wait I was gonna read the destiny roasts
really quick
I don't want to Gaslight you guys into
that hold on okay
I did some screenshots
um all right Destiny is worse for
masculinity than Andrew Tate because
Destiny is so uncool that young man look
at him to do the complete opposite even
if he's right uh my deadly my mom is
deadly sick but left the family leaving
my dad and Bruins your advice would make
me weak sneako and the rest inspire me
to be better than you dust a pool you
think red pillars give bad advice
because you think people are shallow and
stupid and to end up following their own
voices instead of Virtues
um destiny Tech and social media has
replaced the men because of women they
think they don't need us because we
built the technology to make their lives
better the Band of Brothers exist for a
reason in a hyper volatile situations
abandoned Brothers exist for a reason
hyper vital by volatile situations women
can barely relate or want to know how
men feel Destiny I agree oh my gosh oh
wait I have a couple more
um finally someone said it Pearl called
it when Destiny is in a corner debate he
can please he throws something that is
nothing to do with the conversation
thank you Destiny is intelligent but
debates are one with logic and facts not
intelligence and feelings yeah facts
over feelings wow you should debate Ben
Shapiro I would like to see that
actually have you ever tried to debate
with him
um he's too big for me right now I'm
getting there okay I'm gonna I'm gonna
tell him okay yeah you do that okay guys
like the video on your way out thanks
for the roasts thanks for coming thanks
for coming subscribe to the channel
bring that notification Bell and I'll
talk to you next time